- [Voiceover] Hello Grammarians,
hello visiting cousin Beth.
- [Voiceover] Hello cousin David.
- [Voiceover] So today
we're gonna be talking about
pronoun-antecedent agreement.
- [Voiceover] And what is that?
- [Voiceover] An antecedent
is a thing that goes before.
So ante, mean before, and
cedent, is like a going-ee thing.
What I mean by that is that
if we're talking about,
if we setup something in a sentence.
So okay, we've got a sentence
like Jillian rode her bike
to the grocery store.
Fine, straight up
sentence, pretty ordinary.
If we wanna refer to Jillian
again, but we want to use
a pronoun, well, we
refer to Jillian as she.
That's a women's name, so she.
She bought some garlic and
a spoon, like you normally
would when you go to the grocery store.
When we talk about this pronoun she,
in relation to this word,
this proper noun Jillian,
Jillian is the antecedent,
is the thing that goes before
the pronoun she, so that
whenever you use a pronoun,
you are referring back to something else,
the thing that went
before, the antecedent,
the thing that has come previously.
So you want to make sure
that these things match up.
So for example, we know
from living in this culture,
that Jillian is a women's
name, so it would probably be
incorrect to refer to her has he.
Jillian rode her bike
to the grocery store,
he bought some garlic and a spoon.
This sounds like we're
talking about someone else.
So even within this initial sentence too,
Jillian rode her bike
to the grocery store.
We're referring back to Jillian using this
possessive pronoun to define the bicycle.
- [Voiceover] Because
it's a longer sentence.
- [Voiceover] We're
using it to demonstrate
the relationship between
Jillian and the bicycle.
- [Voiceover] Gotcha.
- [Voiceover] You also wanna
to make sure that pronouns
and their antecedent agree in number,
so if you said, what's a fun animal?
- [Voiceover] Monkeys.
So the monkeys threw snowballs,
but they had crummy aim.
So we're using they to
refer back to the monkeys,
so this thing is a plural noun, right?
We're referring to multiple
monkeys, so it would be
incorrect to say the
monkeys threw snowballs,
but it had crummy aim,
because this makes it seem
like we're talking about
one monkey, when in fact,
we're talking about an army
of snowball chucking monkeys.
We got our little monkey, maybe
a calobus or diana monkey.
Got a little tuft, it's
throwing a snowball.
And if that's an Old World
monkey, it probably doesn't
have a fancy tail, this
one has a little tail.
Let's say we have a whole bunch of them,
we want to make sure that
we are operating under
the standards of agreement.
Beth, any questions?
- [Voiceover] So you
can't have it anymore,
because now you've got four monkeys.
- [Voiceover] Right,
let me get rid of that.
What should it be instead Beth?
- [Voiceover] They,
because they is plural,
and we don't know if
they're he's or she's.
- [Voiceover] And even if we didn't,
they kind of eliminates any
kind of gender distinction.
- [Voiceover] Oh right.
- [Voiceover] So the
monkeys threw snowballs,
but they had crummy aim.
Although these monkeys seem
to be doing pretty good
at hitting each others in the heads,
the tails, with their snowballs.
So that's pronoun-antecedent agreement.
So remember to make sure to line things up
when relevant by gender.
Jillian wrote her bike, she
bought some garlic and a spoon.
And by number, so the
monkeys threw snowballs,
but they had crummy aim.
There's more than one
monkey, so you'd wanna use
the plural third person pronoun.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] And Beth out.